good afternoon
colleagues please tell me if we if we're
waiting for uh for anything specific
if not if you are ready then
let me welcome you to this surprise
briefing and that is happening at the
occasion of the visits of
uh of ursula from their lane in
slovakia and you'll be informed by the
prime minister of the the slovak
republic eduard heger and also the
president of the european commission
ursula von der leyen
thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank
the citizens of slovakia it is a great
honor for me to welcome the president of
the european commission
van
ursula
len ursula thank you for coming thank
you for your visit and for a very
constructive
discussion that we had
uh let me inform you about uh individual
topics that we covered today and let me
perhaps start with a very positive
message and that is that
that the world is united in condemning
the russian aggression and the war in
ukraine
141 countries condemned
[Music]
the aggression to ukraine and this is a
great signal that people and countries
and citizens
in the 21st century want to live in
peace they don't want a war they want to
live in peace 21st century should be the
the century of peace
and
that all communities want to live in
peace and this is a great signal and all
we were mobilized in just a few days and
it showed us the new phase of the world
that we are happy to see
uh i
informed the president uh about the
situation at our borders as you
very well know i visited our border
crossings in vishna nimitzke yesterday i
also visited the coordination center in
sobranza and are informed about
everything that is happening there
i'm very happy to
to be able to inform about a great
collaboration between the the state
bodies uh the ngos the
churches uh
and the common people we see a great
solidarity and cooperation now there are
slovaks and also other nations helping
directly at the border a curious
situation for example
students of in students from
india that are studying in kosciutz came
there as volunteers and they are helping
to welcome the refugees that are fleeing
the war so we can see that this is a
joint effort there is a clear spirit of
solidarity and a warm welcome of
people that are fleeing a dangerous
situation
we discussed also about how to
how to achieve a financing
of these efforts and there we again see
a great solidarity of all the member
states
resources were made available at the
european level and mechanisms are being
prepared for distributing them to the
individual member states especially to
those that are experiencing and the
greatest
greatest pressures but also to other
countries that are involved in
in helping people
in need that are fleeing the war and
there are two
uh two
different groups of people the
ukrainians usually women and children
that are fleeing the war but also
a third country nationals uh that
studied or worked in ukraine and they
are trying to
get back home to their home countries so
here we will collaborate again to help
them to get back to their home countries
i also
also informed the president that
slovakia adopted legislation allowing it
to
to
to have a temporary refuge in
slovakia what it means is that
when they ask for the status
they just fill in a form and within a
few minutes they can
feel here as us at home and that means
they can work here they get social
insurance automatically and they
have a legal stay in slovakia and they
get some social benefits as well we also
offer to these people
trains for free they don't have to use
vignettes for using highways
and they can also
travel to other countries if they wish
so we also talked about sanctions
we stated that even though
or
or some expectations uh
where that or some people expected that
the sanctions would be adopted to even
uh quick even more quickly than we did
it but i have to say that this is this
was unprecedented speed
sometimes in the past some
some decisions took years
to make then during the pandemic we were
able to do it in
in months and weeks but at the latest
development showed us that 27
governments and 27 countries can act
very quickly within days and within
hours and i'm very happy that the
democratic
democratic community of all the
countries show showed this um show this
fast coordination
and everyone is ready to help they work
day and night to
clearly show a signal that we are
condemning the war and they are fighting
at the evil and
and we we stand for the peace we want to
live in the century of the peace not
only in europe but in
the entire world and i'm happy that so
many countries joined us in that uh and
the unity is also manifested by the fact
that we're not giving up we want to
support uh ukraine in um
we want to provide humanitarian aid and
other aid and we will continue to
support them until the aggression will
end
that the last
point we talked about is at the energy
sector because we know very well that
not only slovakia but also
other countries of the european union
are are dependent on
on uh russian oil and gas well now we're
talking about measures that are being
planned that need to be put on table as
soon as possible so that we can become
independent of these
sources
so that we have a clear alternative
now of course
i'm talking about gas about oil and also
nuclear fuel
to conclude let me say that
all these activities that are happening
show a
very clear signal also for our citizens
we want to assure everyone that we are
on the right side of the history
we are in the community of the strongest
countries
and
we can
we can be rational and we can we can
help ukraine and we don't have to be
afraid about our own uh future and now i
would like to uh thank uh i would like
to ask
ursula from the lion for
her
we are really to thank you
and to thank the slovak people
for their outstanding effort to support
and welcome
the people that are fleeing the war in
ukraine
and i think in this very dark hour
it is wonderful to see the unity
and to see the solidarity that really
sheds a positive light on a very very
difficult situation
we know that hundreds of thousands of of
people are fleeing putin's bombs in
ukraine
they are leaving their homes they are
leaving their lives behind
at least more than one million people so
far have crossed our borders
and slovakia alone has taken in 80 000
up to now
welcomed 80 000 provided them with food
and
shelter
and
human warmth
i really want to commend the slovakian
people and you prime minister for that
we've seen very touching examples
for example in senina
stefan drove around town to collect
supplies pillows blankets food
and set up a dormitory in the local gym
or the story from switnik where yaroslav
and svetlana are now sharing their roof
with four ukrainian women and their
children
while their husbands stayed behind to
fight for their country
or the story of the bus driver who was
sent to the border to pick up eight
students and he was so moved by that
that he returned and took up another
picked up another 50 ones just to help
and these are just individual examples
but they show what the slovak people are
doing today slovakia has really stepped
up
to welcome refugees and we are very very
grateful for that
we should not forget
that it was a convoy from slovakia
that was the very first
to reach keefe
when the invasion started and this too i
really thank you because this
is an example of european solidarity at
its best
now the european union as a whole
is also of course supporting all those
people who are fleeing this war
first of all we will make sure that we
offer them effective and fast protection
and this is why the european commission
proposed a so-called temporary
protection mechanism
that means that the refugees from
ukraine
immediately get residency rights here
in the european union for guaranteed a
year
can be automatically
prolonged for two years
that means access to the labor market
access to schools for the children
access immediately also too
medical care you were the example with
doing the national legislation
and we now cover that for the whole of
the european union
for at least two years so that these
people ukrainians coming to the european
union are immediately welcomed here have
residency rights and can proceed
in parallel we have issued guidelines
for border management here it's so
important to simplify procedures
so the temporary protection mechanism
also makes it very very simple
because we know more refugees will come
and we have to be fast to give them
immediately a possibility a perspective
to be here but also that they can move
on to other parts of the european union
the second topic i want to mention
is humanitarian support
humanitarian support to deal with the
consequences of this war
inside the countries and of course for
refugees
i've announced yesterday in the european
parliament that we will deploy at least
500 million euros from the eu budget
for humanitarian assistance for refugees
we know this is just the beginning
but we want to signal to you we know
that is an enormous effort
that all the countries now that are at
the border of ukraine are doing to
welcome the refugees we stand by your
side and of course this also means that
we share the burden and europe is there
for you to compensate
we need this is a topic that is for me
important now also to get assistance
into ukraine
to the people who need it desperately
and for that we must open humanitarian
corridors
humanitarian convoys need a safe passage
and civilians must be allowed to leave
the besieged cities
in a safe way
and therefore russia must allow our
humanitarian partners to deliver this
assistance to the people that are in the
war zone
in the unwavering support for ukraine we
are also responding with very strong
measures
one point that is important for me here
in slovakia is also that first of all i
want to
commend you and thank you
for offering the humanitarian hub or we
sometimes also call it a civil
protection hub that is additional now
this is very important because that
allows us to get in the assistance from
other member states here for example to
the
humanitarian hub you're building up
and divided distributing him it to the
region
so many thanks for your willingness to
host this hump
many things for your pragmatism that you
have we bring in the expertise the
professionals who know how to deal with
these crisis instantly
and that will also be able to organize
for example other supporters from the
united nations or from ngos
to really have the red cross for example
to really have the help speedily coming
to the people who desperately need it
then there is another topic and these
are the sanctions against the russian
leadership for the war
by choice they have brought to ukraine
our aim is to stop this invasion and to
cut off
the kremlin's possibility and capacity
to finance this war against its
neighbors
that's why we have introduced these
massive sanctions at an unprecedented
speed within hours
and these sanctions are also applied by
our allies and partners
so far more than 40 countries worldwide
have aligned completely with our
sanctions and you were mentioning the
landslide victory yesterday in the
united nations general assembly with 141
countries condemning
russia's
war brought
to you the ukraine neighbors
the three waves of sanctions that we
have already introduced
have a massive impact on the russian
economy and therefore on putin's war
efforts
and we will introduce additional
measures if the situation deteriorates
on the ground
and finally indeed you mentioned it we
also have to be prepared
for retaliation measures
by russia and the kremlin
and one big topic is lng
and energy
and indeed as of today we can say that
we are able as a european union
even if we would be completely decoupled
from russian gas
to make it through this heating season
our friends all over the world that
supply lng are willing to step up
the supplies of lng so with the storage
that we have and with the additional lng
supplies from partners all over the
world we're able to make it through this
winter and we are preparing now
to get
rid of this dependency of russian gas
and to go into new sources to diversify
our sources of energy supply
on top of the list is of course are of
course the renewables
because the renewables are clean
they are homegrown so it's a strategic
investment
that we do in investing in the
renewables it's also a strategic
investment
in our independence
from the russian fossil fuels
as the bombs continue to fall we pay
tribute to the determination
and the bravery of the people of ukraine
and the outstanding leadership of
president zelinski
they are an inspiration to all of us
and we will never forget
how they stand up in these difficult
days for our values
for the principles of independence and
freedom
but likewise we will never forget the
solidarity of the slovak people
uh i have a question for both the prime
minister and the president uh the prime
minister to you to know how much we get
from the package of 500 million and do
do we know uh what we are going to spend
it on and then i would like to ask the
president if the union
will help uh help those countries in the
eastern and central europe
that are dependent on the russian energy
well
uh let me point out one thing that i
would that we also discussed with uh uh
uh uh with
the president uh i think the unity
surprised also the president putin
and if you're asking how much would get
this is not on the table at all because
we have an absolute solidarity it's not
about percentages every country is
contributing as much as it can so
i assume that this is about um about
cordiality
and
usually you receive more than
than
than
you give if you're a cordial so we will
certainly get uh
everything that we need for for covering
our needs we are all uh as one in this
so
the money will not be your problem at
the european
union so
what we're talking about even about
about 100 coverage but as i said this is
not a matter of the money it's a matter
of being human
very noble answer
rest assure that the european solidarity
of course
is there to support a country like
slovakia in what you're doing now
you have enormous expenses
the staff that is working you need to
give food water shelter to the refugees
and of course we stand up together as
europeans from the european budget
to support slovakia in that
the biggest gift you are giving is the
human warmth and the reception of the
refugees this is priceless if i may say
so
on your second question if i got it
right whether slovakia will benefit from
the gas solidarity of course
i mean we have in the last years
invested heavily in lng terminals that's
good
because that helps us now we have from
all over the world starting with the
united states but other suppliers egypt
for example are also who want to step up
their lng
supplies to the european union we have
more than 25 lng terminals
to get the resources and thanks to a
massive investment over the last years
in pipelines and interconnectors
we have a pipeline network all over the
european union
that enables us to basically send the
gas to where it is needed
and therefore of course
slovakia will be supported if need be
on top we still have the storage
slovakia also has quite substantial
storage and this combination makes it
for us possible
to in case of decoupling of russian gas
to make it
now throughout the winter with the own
supplies that we are able to get
bloomberg
any other question of bloomberg
from bloomberg i would like to ask the
president uh
how the the european commission will
respond uh to uh the application for
becoming a member of the european union
from the side of ukraine so now what
should be the response and then now we
see that also moldavia and
georgia
show their interest as well
i think it is very important
first of all to say
that these brave people in ukraine
that are willing to fight for our common
universal values
and to die for our universal values
belong in our european family without
any doubt
now indeed president zelinski has sent a
letter on ukraine's application
and indeed there is
the
moldova
and georgian wish also to send a letter
concerning an application
and by that
president celensky has set a process
in motion
and this process is now evolving
it will be the next step that the
leaders the member states will discuss
that
but there is a process ongoing and this
is a positive development
um we have before the war already had
special outstanding relationship with
ukraine
i always emphasize that we have started
to integrate the different
markets
strong economic ties
we have been working intensively on
energy security for ukraine that pays
off now in these days
we have the deep and comprehensive free
trade agreement
with ukraine so a lot of steps have
already been done in the days before the
war
now with this application a process is
put in motion
and it
will be discussed in the appropriate
different settings
what i can add to that was that uh is
that slovakia was one of the first
country uh that
supported ukraine in their ambition to
become a member of the eu and it's only
natural we are their neighbor we
understand them
and our mutual relations uh uh are got
uh
very intensive i would like to share a
story you know that that we heard on
uh on a thursday uh from a former uh
prime minister
uh
and uh uh who who oh it was a prime
prime minister of slovenia um
and uh he said that
when they set their application back in
the 90s and
and
that it was a very important moment for
them when they received a a promise or a
positive motion so uh i believe that it
is equally important to send the signal
to ukraine as well and
dr president uh was very clear in saying
that they are part of our
european family and the many members of
the european uh union share
this vision and this uh this reflects
how we see our ukrainian friends the
last thing that i would like to say to
that is that
last thursday we
we woke up to a new world and that is
why we have to look for new ways we have
to come up with new rules so that we
allow country that is in a very unique
situation unlike any other country that
are that have the ambition there to
become a member of the eu this country
is tried by war is devastated by war and
will be devastated
by by the war
let's hope that they will they will keep
their independence they will keep their
government um but
unfortunately if the when the war is
over they will be devastated
so we will
we will need to help them and support
them to get back on their feet as soon
as possible
and this new way of thinking uh i think
this will be reflected in our mutual
communications and negotiations and we
will find ways how to bring them to to
our family as soon as possible thank you
and this is moldova and georgia i just
want to be very clear that they have our
unwavering support too
and moldova you were mentioning moldova
is hosting also many many refugees
therefore
help and support from the european union
is guaranteed in kind but also
financially it's outstanding what
moldova is doing at the moment being
taking in refugees from their neighbor
ukraine and of course we support them in
dealing with that situation but also
to make it possible for the refugees to
move on to the european union
thank you and have a nice day